that co-maid awake no they don't they
call me wig a new bill bill Wiggins hey
youtubers is Charlie time for my
breakdown of his last vow thank you so
much for your patience these are a lot
of fun to make so I try to take a little
extra time just to make them that much
better if you're finding me for the
first time or you haven't seen any of my
Sherlock videos before this is going to
be a breakdown of all the Canon
references in the episode as well as do
some interesting facts about the
production careful for the east wind if
you haven't seen the episode yet
I mean spoilers careful for spoilers so
here we go number one the director Nick
Quran Quran also directed the Doctor Who
50th anniversary episode the day of the
doctor number two Charles Augustus
Madison he's a direct reference to
Charles Augustus Milverton he was
Doyle's master blackmailer and a few of
Magnussen's character traits are taken
directly from the book character like
his glasses and his creepy affable
nature number three
notice the heads up display this isn't a
Canon reference but it is the worst
Google glass ad ever and later we find
out it actually has nothing to do with
the classes but cybernetic implants I
guess that makes him part Cyberman
number four speaking of Doctor Who
notice the woman he's scanning that's
Lindsay Duncan who played Adelaide
Brooke during waters of Mars later she
even remarks about how wet Magnussen's
hands feel number five
notice cams license plate it almost
looks like it says I can during the
episode cam states that he does things
just because he can number six
clair de la lune the perfume serves as
connective tissue between lady Smallwood
cam Mary and Sherlock it's French for
light of the moon and was a lullaby with
a very sexual double entendre in the
episode it just represents the dual
identity that mary has number seven the
man with the twisted lip this is an easy
one but starting from the beginning a
woman comes in to visit Mary looking for
her son Isaac Whitney Watson thinks it's
her husband in the book it was actually
her husband number 8 the drug den also
in the twisted lip Watson find Sherlock
Holmes while looking for the woman's
husband whose name is Isaac nee in the
can Holmes was mostly a cocaine user
but he also used morphine and visited
the occasional opium den note that all
these drugs were perfectly legal in late
19th century England now that sounds
like a party number 9 call me cezzah
Sherlock uses it as his undercover name
in the novel his last bow Holmes also
uses an undercover name it's at Lamont
the middle name of Conan Doyle's father
number 10
they call me Wiggy Billy Wiggins is two
Canon characters merged into one
Billy was name of Holmes page boy he was
in the valley of fear the problem of the
Thor bridge and the Mazarin stone
Wiggins was the leader of the Baker
Street Irregulars he appeared in
studying scarlet and Santa for number 11
when Sherlock is describing Magnussen to
Watson
his speech when you stand before the
serpents of the zoo is lifted directly
from the book number 12 cross-dressing
would have been a wiser path for you in
Cannon Holmes did this at least three
times including the adventure black
Peter the adventures of the final
problem and adventure the empty house
number 13 where should we be looking in
Cannon Holmes used to hide shag tobacco
in the toe of his Persian slipper
we actually sought Cumberbatch's
Sherlock hides cigarettes in the toe of
a slipper during saina 3:14 you've got a
girlfriend the cannon Holmes got engaged
to milverton's housemaid as part of his
case technically though Janine really
didn't have time to accept Sherlock's
proposal in the episode thanks to a
swift blow to the head number 15
mrs. Hudson's rap sheet when Magnussen
scans mrs. Hudson he learns that her
original name was Sissons she's only a
semi reformed alcoholic and a former
exotic dancer notice the C file note
later Sherlock makes a similar reference
and mrs. Hudson accuses him of a
youtubing so somewhere in the world of
the show there's a young naked mrs.
Hudson dancing her way across YouTube
and she has a bit of a problem with
marijuana number 16 Breaking and
Entering Sherlock and Watson also break
into milverton's home in the cannon
number 17 the east wind is coming home
says this in last bow it means the great
change is coming in the Canon it was
actually referring to the advent of
World War one in the context of the show
after Sherlock is shot the East one
represents death but later in the
episode
it's the spectre of Moriarty number 18
red beard we finally learned that red
beard was Sherlock's childhood dog who
had to be put to sleep
number 19 Sussex Downs Janine sells the
story to the tabloids it buys a cottage
in Sussex Downs with a bit of a V
problem in the Canon Holmes retires to a
pharmacist
downs and keeps bees as a hobby number
20 boltholes
Sherlock Holmes has six known bolt holes
including Parliament Hill Gambon lock
dagmar Court the blind greenhouse and
Kew Gardens the leaning tomb in
Hampstead Cemetery behind the clockface
in big ben and line stir Gardens 21 the
lie and line stir Gardens the fake house
is a reference to the story empty house
which deals with what hides behind
facades 22 the dynamics of combustion we
learned that Sherlock and Mycroft's
mother was a genius mathematician before
retiring to raise a family thus becoming
the source of all genius on the show 23
a GRA in Canon the sign of four includes
a treasure plot originating in Agra
India 24 why do you hate him so much
can Holmes would often take justice into
his own hands when he felt the law dot
during the Milverton Adventure Holmes
allows me Overton to be shot by another
person without trying to stop her
because he considers the killing to be
justified in the episode Sherlock dated
himself but the spirit is the same thus
fulfilling his last vow 25 Sherlock
Holmes Dragonslayer Sherlock says to
Mycroft is that what you think of me
referring to Magnussen is the dragon in
question but before his last vow was
shot Kummer batch had just completed
filming his role as Smaug the dragon on
Hobbit part 2 also starring Martin
Freeman in the same conversation
Mycroft tell Sherlock he shouldn't take
that mi6 job as he has more utility in
England because here be dragons implying
that he watched Sherlock to take out
Magnussen 26 let me flick your face
Stephen Moffat actually said that
Freeman and Nicholson had to perform the
scene several times the two actors had
to find a spot on Freeman's face that
Mickelson could flick for hours without
Freeman wanting to punch Mickelson at
the end of the day 27 unreliable
narrator Sherlock calls himself a
high-functioning sociopath several times
but he specifically acts in the
interests of his own friends which is
completely out of character for an
actual associate path I wonder what else
he's been lying to us about 28 the other
one Mycroft and Sherlock have an older
brother named share inferred he isn't
part of the actual Canon but a noted
home scholar theorized his existence
based on facts from the books so
technically the other one only exists as
a theory
twenty-nine undercover work in Cannon
Holmes went undercover for the English
war effort during the beginning of World
War one 30 did you miss me
the image shown of Moriarty is of him
wearing the same suit from Reichenbach
Fall there are a lot of theories about
whether it's him or whether it's not and
it's just someone using his image but
I'm gonna save a lot of that for my
series 4 predictions video be sure to
subscribe to get it
also if you guys want I'll do another
Q&A video after I post that series 4
predictions video if there were any
Canon references or cool things that you
saw in the episode that it didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments don't forget I'm
doing Musketeers videos with Peter
Capaldi starting this Sunday it's gonna
be a lot of fun right now you can click
here to get my breakdown of episode 2
and click here to get my breakdown
episode 1 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you